,
SPECIAL REPORT, UP NEXT.
>> Bret: AND THANK YOU, QUAN.
I'M BRET BAIER, BREAKING TONIGHT
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS PUSHING FOR
GUN CONTROL, A CHANGE IN THE
SENATE FILIBUSTER AND BETTER
RELATIONS WITH CHINA AND
NORTH KOREA.
HE WANTS TO CHANGE THE PARADIGM
AND WILL DO WHAT HE NEEDS TO GET
THINGS DONE.
HE SAYS HE EXPECTS TO RUN FOR
REELECTION IN 2024, WHAT HE IS
NOT DOING IS FOLLOWING HIS FIRST
FORMAL NEWS CONFERENCE SINCE
TAKING OFFICE IS TAKING
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE CRISIS OF
THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
WE HAVE COMPLETE COVERAGE OF HIS
FIRST SOLO Q&A SESSION WITH
REPORTERS, BUT WE START OFF WITH
WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
PETER DOOCY WHO IS IN THE ROOM,
GOOD EVENING PETER.
>> THERE WERE 30 OF US IN THE
EAST ROOM, WE HE SPOKE FOR AN
HOUR AND 10 MINUTES.
HE CALLED ON TEN REPORTERS WHOSE
NAMES WERE ON A LIST THAT FOX
WAS NOT ON.
>> President Biden: FOLKS, I'M
GOING.
>> BEFORE HE DID, HE SPOKE
GENERALLY ABOUT THE GROWING
NUMBER OF MIGRANTS OF THE BORDER
INCLUDING 11,900 CHILDREN IN
FEDERAL CUSTODY SAYING THEY'RE
NOT COMING BECAUSE OF HIS
POLICIES.
IT >> President Biden: I WOULD
LIKE TO THINK IT'S BECAUSE I'M A
NICE GUY, BUT IT'S NOT.
WE ARE TRYING TO WORK OUT NOW
WITH MEXICO THEIR WILLINGNESS TO
TAKE MORE OF THOSE FAMILIES
BACK.
>> HE SAYS HE'S AWARE SOME
MIGRANT PROCESSING FACILITIES
ARE WAY BEYOND CAPACITY.
>> President Biden: IS THAT A
SERIOUS QUESTION?
COME ON.
IT'S BECOME 21 REPUBLICAN
SENATORS HAVE SAID, YOUR
ADMINISTRATION IS NOT ONLY BEING
DISHONEST BUT ACTIVELY MISS
READING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND
BLOCKING ACCESS TO TRANSPARENCY.
>> I WILL COMMIT TO
TRANSPARENCY.
AS SOON AS I'M IN A POSITION TO
IMPLEMENT WHAT WE'RE DOING RIGHT
NOW.
>> TO BE CLEAR, HOW SOON WILL
THAT BE?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT'S
PROMISING GUN-CONTROL REFORM IN
DUE TIME.
>> SUCCESSFUL PRESIDENTS BETTER
THAN ME HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN
LARGE PART BECAUSE THEY KNOW HOW
TO TIME WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
ORDER IT'S.
>> IF HIS PROGRESSIVE AGENDA
STALLS, HE HAS A WILLINGNESS TO
SUPPORT A MAJOR CHANGE IN SENATE
RULES AND SENDING ANY LAWMAKER
TO FILIBUSTER TO STAND AT THE
MIC THE WHOLE TIME.
>> President Biden: IT USED TO
BE YOU HAD TO STAND THERE AND
TALK AND TALK AND TALK UNTIL HE
COLLAPSED.
GUESS WHAT?
PEOPLE GOT TIRED OF TALKING AND
TIRED OF COLLAPSING.
FILIBUSTERS BROKE DOWN AND WERE
ABLE TO BREAK THE FILIBUSTER AND
GET A VOTE.
I STRONGLY SUPPORT MOVING IN
THAT DIRECTION.
>> SOME OF THE PRESIDENT'S
SHARPEST WORDS WERE ABOUT
STATE-LEVEL REPUBLICAN EFFORTS
TO REGULATE VOTING HOURS AND
ACCOMMODATIONS.
>> President Biden: I'M
WORRIED ABOUT HOW UN-AMERICAN
THIS WHOLE INITIATIVE IS.
IT'S SICK.
TO SPEAK OF THE PRESENT
SUGGESTION IS THAT NO FILIBUSTER
MEANS EASIER PASSAGE OF HR ONE,
BEFORE THE SENATE, REPUBLICANS
CHARGED ABOUT STRIPPING VOTER
I.D. AND MAKING D.C. A STATE
GIVING THEM A PERMANENT
ADVANTAGE IN CONGRESS.
BIDEN SAID IT'S ALL ABOUT
STOPPING REPUBLICANS FROM
CUTTING HOURS AT POLLING PLACES.
IT >> President Biden: THIS
MAKES JIM CROW LOOK LIKE JIM
EAGLE.
>> NOT A FACTOR IN THE 2024
MATCH UP WITH PRESIDENT TERM.
>> President Biden: I HAVE NO
IDEA WHO'S GOING TO BE IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
GO BIDEN SAYS HE STILL EXPECTS
TO RUN FOR REELECTION.
>> President Biden: I'VE NEVER
BEEN ABLE TO PLAN FOR AND A HALF
YEARS AHEAD FOR CERTAIN.
>> RIGHT BEFORE THE Q&A WITH
REPORTERS WITH REPORTERS, THE
PRESIDENT READ FROM SOME
PREPARED REMARKS WHERE HE
ANNOUNCED HIS GOAL INSTEAD OF
100 MILLION COVID-19 VACCINES IN
THIS FIRST 100 DAYS, IS
200 MILLION VACCINES.
DESPITE THE COVID-19 TALK OFF
THE TOP, NO QUESTIONS IN THE
PROGRAM TH